head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts so the other day we're all
watching this trailer for a movie called
Civil War and everyone's like oh gez is
this predictive programming I don't know
but you want to know what we'll make
predictions for you what will be another
grain of sand actually this is a boulder
not a grain of sand BL journalist who
covered January 6 to be charged by Biden
doj the fascinating thing here Richie
McGinnis who was a friend of the show he
was uh uh he covered the uh Kenosha
riots he actually tendered Aid to the
man who was shaal written housee was
also there at January 6 with credentials
as a journalist and he posted an image
of him with Steve Baker a contributor to
The Blaze and an someone who is
unambiguously a journalist he said three
months ago I had a drink with Steve and
told him the doj would not be so
partisan that they would charge him for
his work his his obvious work as a
journalist well he tweeted this my
attorney has just been notified by the
FBI that I'm going to be charged by the
justice department for my journalistic
efforts on January 6 I have to selfs
surrender on Tuesday charges are yet
unknown stay tuned for more information
to follow this
afternoon scary I I I I've warned about
this and I said it was coming they are
now
they they've already gone from if you
weren't even at January 6 20 years in
prison they are now at the EUR
journalist who covered it before this
Owen Shroyer permitted protest did not
go in the building uh uh Owen and Alex
Jones had permits to be at the capital
for a rally and Owen Shroyer was yelling
in the bullhorn they put him in prison
for this for a couple months The Next
Step journalist he was there doesn't
matter they're going to lock him up
despite the fact this guy is like as
journalist as a journalist gets right
the next step I believe is going to be
and I hope y'all are listening to this
one prominent personalities on social
media who have podcasts and vodcasts who
were cheering for January 6 before it
happened and on the day of will be
charged I will I will bet a large sum of
money they will be charged you want to
know why because Enrique tario was not
there but he he posted on I think it was
parlor don't leave they said that was
instruction and incitement and for that
as the leader of the proud boys 20 years
well I was at Enrique taro's trial and
what you're saying makes a lot of sense
actually and there's a really novel
legal theory that they use there that a
lot of people don't know about because
no one covered it which was um it was
it's called the tools theory that even
if you're not there and I think they
were planning on using this with Trump
and they used Enrique Taro kind of as a
pseudo Trump um you could use people in
the crowd is your tool so like if you're
on your podcast saying you know be there
it's going to be wild it's going to be
great they could say that every single
person there you use as a tool and this
is literally what they convicted Enrique
otario with was using the tools Theory
so what you're saying absolutely makes
sense and Jamie Raskin already played a
video montage of numerous personalities
cheering for serious action I'm not
going to quote any of them I'll I'll
keep that one uh but you can easily find
some of these quotes but let me just
tell you there were people who are
prominent social media personalities who
make videos who were in before like the
day before they were saying things like
go there and enter they were saying
things like that right they were saying
more extreme things than that these
people are going to be arrested and I
think they know it because I can tell
you this some of these people have
already
flip-flopped right at so you've got
people who before January 6 were saying
things like people should go there and
people should do X Y and Z there's video
of this they've plated the January 6th
committee hearings shortly after January
6th when they arrest everybody these
people flipped their script they're now
super
anti-trump gee I wonder why I wonder why
I say like Jenna Ellis right working
with Trump all of a sudden is now oh
Trump so bad because they know what's
coming well yeah she started saying that
a while ago because I know she knows
that that indictment was coming which
she now is of course completely
flip-flopped on and she's going to
testify against Trump and Giuliani and
all the others but um I was there at
January 6 you know taking video and I
actually was visited by the FBI and I've
been vocal about this just because I
feel like it's a form of protecting
myself uh and it's it's very scary and a
lot of other journalists there's been a
lot of Talk Amongst journalists that
people that were there that day they're
coming for next so it's a real thing and
I'm not surprised by this I and I know
Steve Baker I follow him on on social
media and he's a good journalist it's
very scary what what's going on right
now in America and you would think that
reporters from CNN or you you know
liberal reporters would be saying this
is wrong you should not be you know what
if somebody uh got arrested a black
lives matter rally for covering it and
there was violence there I'm sure that
they would be speaking out against that
and they don't realize that this could
flip-flop like you know 5 years from now
the political pendulum could swing I
think the other way and they could be
arrested the Owen Shroyer precedent he
did not go in the building right I
believe that there is a strong
possibility after they start going so
look they went after Owen Shroyer why he
was B horning now they're going after a
journalist why narrative
control I I don't see any logical reason
why they would ignore these social media
personalities who weren't even there but
were making videos cheering it on there
were some personalities that as it was
happening were posting saying things
like why is anyone mad about this y'all
and they're like yo it was crazy people
who were there tweeting stuff that I get
but there were people who are posting
videos to tens of thousands of people to
hundreds of thousands of people saying
it was a good thing well those people
are likely going to get arrested I would
say that would be for protective free
speech and a question for the Supreme
Court and so is so is what owener did
they still use it in a sentencing
guidelines and what they're going to
argue is these people facilitated and
incited and that is not protected speech
right they're going to say instruction
to commit a crime is not protected
speech they've already gotten people FL
that believe it or not they're not big
podcasters but there was a guy that I
know that was there that day and he was
putting stuff out on on social media and
he had like 10 followers and then he was
in the goog in DC for a couple he was in
he was there on January no he wasn't he
was not there on January 6 he uh he was
in DC but he never went anywhere near
the capital and they said that because
it was because of his um actual tweets
and his actual stuff on social media and
it had it had something to do with
Interstate like uh something I don't
even know what they charged him with but
it was this really weird thing like
crossing State Communications crossing
state lines because he was tweeting on
social media so another I think this is
less likely but also possible I think
the indictment charging arrest or the
coercion of of social media
personalities with podcasts and vodcasts
I think that's 100% meaning you guys
listening I'm not going to say anybody's
names or quotes because I'm going to
leave that to them but you you can
probably think at the top of your head a
handful of people who have shows who
advocated for what was going on before
and the day of but the next thing I
think is possible is people who didn't
even go to the capital but were near the
capital will likely be charged as well
oh yeah that's what everyone's been
waiting for people text me all the time
because they know I report on this stuff
people that would in DC like grandmas
Aunts Uncles and stuff oh my God car I'm
so afraid I'm so afraid do you think
that I'm going to get arrested I was
there that day I was just watching Trump
speech are they going to come to my
house and arrest me so this sets just a
terrible precedent because in 2024 who
on God's planet is going to show up for
a political protest especially when it
involves Trump and they know this
they're just completely shock and awe
with everybody if you were in DC on
January 6th but nowhere near the capital
as you've already mentioned but we
tweeting things they'll come after you
as you already mentioned they did for
for for this one guy so there are people
who probably saw Trump speak never went
to the capital just left but we're
tweeting things and they will say we
have evidence that you were there in DC
encouraging and inciting the people
around you to go and do this and they
did therefore you're going to get
incitement charged I will also add and I
think everybody listening to this can
name some people off top of their head
how many people have fled the country
already
several I haven't been keeping tabs is
it who or is it worth talking about I am
not going to name people who have
already fled the country but uh I think
people who are listening already know
there are several people who are there
or who are in DC and they've fled the
United States and the FEDS are probably
going to say that they were accessories
to the crime um this is this is
political prosecution this is my tax
dollars being sent to intimidate and
stop journalists journalism and from
people actually doing legitimate work on
the ground this guy Steve Baker just
tweeted yes I entered the capital like
about 60 other journalists quote did no
damage or parading or violence why are
we spending resources from the Federal
Bureau of Investigations that is
supposed to be going after traffickers
individuals who hurt children why are we
diverting those issues and that specific
important cause why is that cause being
ignored to go after someone who walked
in a federal building it's political
prose well no I mean I'll tell you uh
you know let's let's let's say you uh
fry up some bacon and burgers and other
really great food and you're you're
having a you're having dinner with your
friends and and then once you finish you
don't you don't rinse your dish right
away you just eat and hang out but after
you're done you're like ah I got all
this Gunk stuck to the pan what do you
do soak it for soak it overs yeah why
because then scrubbing it becomes easier
now let's talk about what they're doing
why go after journalists and you know
bumbling dotards because then The Purge
in 2024 or 5 will be easier this is the
soak this is this is where they are
putting journalists in jail they're
trying to put the president in jail the
former president they're going after uh
not just this one journalist other
personalities and they're going after
more importantly I think the scarier
thing is people who showed up an hour or
two after the events of January 6 when
the doors are open there's no Gates
anywhere and the police are letting
people in and they're calling they're
charging them the same as the riers this
is soaking the pen because if they went
and tried to round up Trump supporters
in 2425 for no reason just instantly you
you you it' be chaos but they got to
soften it up a little bit more grains of
sand in the Heap now people are like oh
it's political persecution but it's
being normalized right that so you do it
one at a time if if the feds went after
Alex Jones instantly you'd get you get
riots I think they're going to go after
Alex Jones I believe that Alex Jones
will likely be charged over January I
think that you know what protected him
was him on his megaphone telling
everybody to go home go home go home I
guess that you like you said this maybe
stuff I don't know I'm not not aware of
what he said prior to January 6th or
what people on his show said I know he
had oathkeepers on his show and and
proud Boys on his show that were I don't
think that
matters I mean like I feel bad for Alex
Jones He I do he's one of the most
politically persecuted I actually
founded an organization called citizens
against political persecution and this
was three years ago never in my life did
I think three years after the fact of
January 6 would this still be going on
we're going on three years now of
January 6 people are getting arrested
every day there's still people in
solitary confinement right now as we
speak sitting there pre-trial and they
plan I'm sure using 2024 to continue to
shock in awe and arrest more Trump
supporters because I don't know what's
going to happen on the election in 2024
but if anyone protests and if anyone
dare says it was an IL legitimate
election then now they know that they
you know have four years of judicial
precedent to look back on and say you
know we could just throw these people in
jail throw the key away and nobody's
going to say anything about it because
nobody has yeah it's almost as if
they're trying to provoke a reaction
it's almost as if they're trying to piss
as many people off as they can because
this is egregious this is this is not
the behavior of a real justice
department this is not the behavior of
federal agents that are supposed to be
going after crime there was there was
essentially with this journalist what
what crime was was committed why are we
doing this and to me I'm thinking later
down the line like hey maybe they are
trying to really anger some people so
they react in a certain way that's going
to be more advantageous for the system
later down the line right they want to
provoke a reaction for which they can
start arresting people
yep they need another January 6th that's
why I keep saying I said over and over
and over again no violence you've got to
vote and I think there's a uh like Scott
Adams tweeted something uh I could be
wrong maybe it wasn't Scott but uh some
uh someone tweeted that Trump has the
vote margins right now that make fraud
irrelevant to the conversation his
margins when you look at Trump's vote
count in 2020 and how he was polling he
got more votes than any sitting
president in history and Joe Biden got
more votes than any candidate in history
and the reason Biden got those votes for
the most great a great deal of those
votes that he gets are because of
universal mailin voting Now by all means
go ahead and believe that uh you know
like sunny huson and others were filling
out ballots for other people that's not
my point my point is the first stage in
all of this is universal mail and voting
to create the possibility of those votes
existing Trump's polling so high right
now that even if they went tenfold what
they were doing with with with Trump
with with Biden they wouldn't come close
and I mean that figuratively but they
had full lockdowns Universal mail and
voting and Biden was was was able to
pull off 81 million right now there's no
way even if they have Universal mail
voting and sunny huson says claims she
voted for her son again whatever that
means and and moms are doing that stuff
and they're doing ballot harvesting and
ballot chasing and all of that Trump
still wins what they desperately need
and by they I mean the neocons the
neoliberals and the Deep State the un
party establishment what they
desperately need is in 2024 there to be
some kind of January 6 type event well
that's what I've been fearing I don't
you know I know something is coming up
in 2024 and I live in New York City so I
don't know if it's going to be there and
I feel like it's going to be a false
flag event I don't know if it's going to
be another pandemic or I thought it a
year or two ago when they were doing
those Invasion Alien Invasion
Congressional hearings they were going
to tell us aliens had landed and we all
have to stay in our house or if there's
going to be a nuclear threat or
something like that but there's going to
be something big that happens in 2024 in
order to I think affect the election you
know that that I'm not a conspiracy
theorist I'm not trying to sound like
one but I think everybody knows that I
have elderly relatives who are liberals
who say to me all the time something's
not right this I've never seen anything
so bad something bad is going to happen
something bad is going to happen it's
like we're all being subliminally
prepped somehow and everybody keeps
saying the same thing I'm sure you've
heard it something bad is going to
happen I think that something bad is
going to be in 2024 and it's going to
affect the outcome of the election well
uh Jones and poic think we could go to
full scale war with Russia by next
October and then that that would uh
here's the funny thing you know Roseanne
says there's not going to be an election
right if we are in full scale World War
II you may very well see a suspended
election well it's martial law it's
emergency Powers it's it's the
government saying Presidential Directive
51 thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net MERS only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time